the US Justice Department has confirmed
that a 56 year old
Cesaro seoc is the man in custody in
connection the recent wave of mail bombs
targeting senior political figures
officials say they identified his
fingerprints and DNA from one of the
envelopes he allegedly sent he has been
charged today with five federal crimes
including interstate transportation of
an explosive illegal mailing of
explosives threats against former
presidents and certain other persons
threatening interstate communications
and assaulting current and former
federal officers so let's look at what
we know about the suspect Cesaro seoc
he's apparently a trump supporter for
years living in a van covered in
pro-trump and bumper stickers Sayoko
also already has a criminal record he
was previously convicted of car theft if
found guilty of the attempted parcel
bombings he could face up to 58 years in
prison among the targets of his 13
packages were Barack Obama Hillary
Clinton and CNN meantime Donald Trump
has condemned the incident we will
prosecute them him/her whoever it may be
to the fullest extent of the law
we must never allow political violence
to take root and America cannot let it
happen and I'm committed to doing
everything in my power as president to
stop it
the attempted bombings highlight how
polarized the US has become certainly
ahead of midterm elections in just over
a week and this is confirmed by a new
survey which found that 80% of Americans
think their country is greatly divided
it also found that almost 40% of those
polled
believe the situation will worsen the
poll also revealed that among the most
contentious political issues are Donald
Trump's presidency
economic inequality and race relations
well lawyer and political activist a
Christian man chera told us there needs
to be a concerted effort to bring people
together both sides have to tone it down
both the president and the
Media and other political sectors have
to come together and understand that we
cannot continue sending these
inflammatory comments on TV and on
social media because there are people
who take it personally and then they
think that they have a way to respond
and this is one example now is the
Republican side that has this crazy
follower and we also had this Democratic
extreme left follower a few a few months
ago when he attack congressman Scalise
so I think that we have to be very
careful because this is becoming a real
problem now and while many in the u.s.
feel that divisions will only worsen
some in the mainstream media initially
pointed the finger at Russia as being
behind the parcel bombs I have this fear
that it could be some Russian operation
to InDesign to do what's happening now
you